hello there my name's gavin and welcome
to this episode of the slow mo guys very
oddly presented from my living room
a while ago i made a video called how a
camera works in slow-mo and the response
was great
so i thought a good natural progression
to that video would be how a tv works in
slow-mo
this is an 85-inch lcd tv and whenever
i'm playing something on it
or watching something on it my eyes and
brain are being
misled and tricked giving me the
illusion
of watching a moving object when in fact
i'm just watching
several still images just shown to me
very very fast
if i'm watching a film i'm being shown
24 images
every second and to my eyes that looks
like i'm looking at a moving object when
in fact i'm looking at
24 individual pictures if i'm playing a
game it's the same except maybe
30 to 60 frames a second and if i'm on a
pc it could be hundreds
pc master is but a tv like this is
actually incapable of showing you one
image
and then a 24th of a second later just
switching all at once to the next image
and to illustrate this next point
i'm going to use a very old and very
crap
crt tv that stands for cathode ray tube
if you've ever seen one of these filmed
you may notice that it looks slightly
different
on camera than it does to your eye
look at that the reason it looks like
this is because
the shutter speed of this camera is out
of sync with the refresh rate
of this screen the frame is constructed
from the top
to the bottom multiple times per second
that's 60 times in the us 60 hertz
i've prepared for you some high speed
footage that i shot a long time ago on
the v2511
of this screen and this screen and some
others um a lot of it is
dan playing super mario on the nes
extremely badly
here's the tv and the cat played back at
25 this is how it would be perceived in
real time
and now at 1600 frames a second you can
actually see the scan line
moving from the top to the bottom you'll
notice that on a crt screen
it's only the active line of pixels
that's bright and your persistence of
vision will actually build that into a
complete image
what's messing with my eyes this
trip it's like a dance floor
oh didn't even make it that's the first
guy
slowed all the way down to 2500 frames a
second you can now differentiate each
individual frame
being built from top to bottom
it takes an extremely fast camera to see
that each frame is built
line by line from top to bottom but it
takes an even
faster camera to see that each line is
drawn from left to right
slow down to 28 500 frames a second
we're now seeing glimpses of that
but we do need to go even slower
this is now 118 000 frames a second i'm
going to put the stats up for you here
so you can see the actual amount of time
that it took and you can see now that
the line is being drawn
from left to right on the screen now 146
000 frames a second to gain perspective
on just how slow this actually is
you can see the exact time i shot this
so this is hours it was just past
midnight 23 minutes
41 seconds this is a tenth of a second a
hundredth of a second
one thousandth of a second or a
millisecond and then over here you've
got a ten thousandth of a second
a hundred thousandth of a second and
this unit here is the
millionth of a second or a microsecond
we are now at 380 000 frames a second as
our recording frame rate that is the
highest frame rate we've
ever shot so far on this channel and
using this information here's a little
bonus fact
a crt screen can draw mario's mustache
in less than a 380 000
of a second that is some seriously fast
facial hair
and if you're wondering why this footage
looks extremely mucky and blurry
is because the resolution is only
256x128
which plonked into a 4k frame is this
big
that crt screen is standard def this is
a 4k
screen which means it's 3840
by 2160 pixels that's over 8 million
pixels
so think of the processing power that
this tv has to have
to update an image that big that many
times every second the first thing
you'll notice about a modern lcd screen
is that it's not only the active line of
pixels that retains brightness it's the
entire image
so you can actually see the full image
as each scan line passes down the screen
this is every frame
of the startup sequence on an xbox one
[Music]
i also recorded myself playing a game of
halo nothing will make you feel worse
about your performance than watching
your
lousy aim in slow-mo look at that it's
crazy to think that when you're playing
halo this is actually what is happening
on your tv
if only you could see it at the speed
your aim would be incredible
it honestly makes me feel bad when i
fall asleep watching tv knowing that
this tv is doing all this intensive work
changing literally tens of millions of
pixels
every second and there's no one there
watching it here's a fun fact the same
applies
to an iphone except it's in portrait
mode
so if you're watching a video in
landscape mode on your iphone
you're actually getting updates from
left to right or right to left depending
on which way you flipped it
and that just proved to me that you
can't see the refresh direction with
your naked eye because i had no idea
whenever i was watching a youtube video
on my iphone
that the screen was updating in a
completely different direction i'm not
sure if this is the case for all
smartphones but it's certainly the case
on an iphone 7 plus which is what i
filmed this on
so we've talked about one illusion of
tvs the illusion of movement
the second illusion i want to talk about
is the illusion of color
for this next part i'm going to need a
second camera here's one
that's you i love you so in order to
film this screen extremely close
i have to set my focus at the minimum
possible distance
so it's sort of like right here now set
to my minimum focus
as i slowly move towards the screen it
becomes sharper and you will then at the
last minute see
a very odd looking pattern and what
you're seeing there
is an effect caused by the camera this
camera trying to resolve
individual pixels on the surface of this
screen
as i push further forward the effect
disappears
and everything goes out of focus that's
because i'm now beyond
the minimum focal distance of this lens
which is about
what's about there not close enough
in order to get closer i'm gonna need a
macro lens
here's one as i approach the white
and everything starts to become in focus
you can see that white isn't so white
anymore it looks like i have to go
closer
even than that thankfully
i can go all the way to five times
magnification
now one thing from this point i am
definitely gonna need a tripod because
there's no way
my arms are sturdy enough to hold this
in place but uh i'll just ease it in
just to show you
the level of magnification we're talking
about now
well it's close it's a different story
altogether i'm gonna get a tripod
here's one what a mission this is
all right let's see what we can do here
we're so close up right now
that i can actually disturb this image
by blowing on the lens
we're now looking at the sub pixel level
a pixel is made up of three
sub pixels red green and blue rgb
you may have heard that before and this
creates the illusion of different colors
by dimming and brightening different sub
pixels to different intensities
this screen can create the illusion of
literally
millions of different colors when all
three are lit
to full brightness you get white when
all three dim you go through gray all
the way down to black
so if green dims away and red and blue
are still lit then you go into magenta
purple that sort of area and that's how
the colors are made
so every time on your tv you're looking
at a white image
you're looking at tons of blue
green and red lights they're just so
small
they look like white to your eye before
you get white
red green and blue blurs into yellow
cyan and magenta
and that's what happens here when i move
the screen slightly out of focus
this is too close to watch a slow-mo
guys video
i might vomit it's the same situation
just entire blocks and they're bigger
as i mentioned before this is a 4k lcd
screen
which a while back were typically lit by
ccfls
or a cold cathode fluorescent lamp which
means the entire panel is
backlit by fluorescent tubes nowadays
they are backlit by leds this is why
this would actually be marketed as an
led
tv the benefit of led screens over ccfl
screens is that they're a lot thinner
now i'm going to point it at where some
black text is now interestingly even
though this area is black
because all the subpixels have dimmed
they are still in fact
backlit let me show you that right now
now you can see as we push in here you
have to pardon the noise we're in
extremely high iso to get this shot
through a macro lens but you can see
even the dimmed pixels
part of the liquid crystal displays it's
now trying to block all light from
penetrating through but it's still a
backlit
pixel and that's one of the fundamental
limitations of an lcd screen
you can see this effect on an lcd screen
in the credits of a film because you've
got
almost completely black image but
because there's white text the entire
backlight has to be on
to display the white which means light
will leak out from the black pixels
which means it's not true black there is
another technology that's becoming much
more common these days and that is an
oled screen organic light emitting diode
i did want to include a comparison
between an lcd panel and an oled panel
but i didn't actually have an oled tv
and by sheer luck right in the middle of
me shooting all this footage
lg got in touch and offered to supply me
with an oled tv
for the purpose of making this video
which i really appreciate thanks
lg why don't we go and take a look at it
this is a 77 inch
lg oled tv the way oled technology works
is that each pixel is self-illuminating
depending on how much voltage is passing
through it which means there's no global
backlight on the tv
each pixel is individually in control of
how bright it is
and it's not being lit from behind and
that means when we go to our
high iso experiment just like we did on
the lcd
that when there's an area of black on
the screen all of those pixels
are off and you can see here where i'm
putting my cursor in front of the lens
you can see each sub-pixel
lighting up and then completely turning
off when it goes away this technology
means
much deeper blacks and the possibility
of a very thin screen
and there you have it a brief
explanation of how a tv works
in slow-mo if you found that video
interesting chances are
you might find some other videos
interesting on this channel so make sure
you
boop and once you've booped feel free to
check out up
it's just there thank you very much for
watching
that was a good time we won it tv timed
out another fireworks